there's an ancient Arabic legend about a
shape-shifter that can take the form of
any animal they can also appear as a
living column of smoke or dust or a
giant human and have been known to live
trapped in a bottle gin our genes
ancient creatures believed to occupy the
space between celestial and terrestrial
worlds not quite monsters not quite
humans and not quite celestial beings
the jinn are something different but for
many people the genie is just some guy
in a lamp who can give you three wishes
a way for you to get what you want
without having to work for it not only
is that not even close to the original
versions of the jinn it dismisses the
immense power these beings possess the
jinn our species all their own more
powerful than humans and more meaningful
than pop culture would have us believe
I'm dr. Emily szarka and this is
monstrum crafted from prehistoric fires
long before humans jinn are neither
wholly earthly nor wholly spiritual they
require food to live are subject to lust
and other human passions and can die
although they live naturally for
thousands of years jinn can see humans
and interfere in their lives humans can
only see a genie if it takes a form that
allows itself to be seen which is rare
they can move through walls and travel
great distances quickly shape-shifting
into all kinds of animals and can appear
as smoke sometimes the appearance of a
genie is preceded by an earthquake or a
storm in ancient Arabic cultures jinn
were worshipped for their capacity to
make legendary weapons and supposed
ability to encourage fertile crops these
pre-islamic accounts of jinn also
claimed a genie could take on a human
form and have children with them these
offspring were often seers who could
communicate with their jinn relatives as
well as with the divine these half jinn
children were advisors and consultants
of religious matters they helped find
lost animals gave and removed curses and
settled personal disputes Islamic
narratives heavily influenced the
perception of Qin and their
characteristics the Quran explicitly
mentions there are three types of
spiritual beings
angels demons and jinn that text also
states jinn were created before humans
and our intelligent beings with freewill
formed from smokeless fire and scorching
winds in Islamic tradition people made
from clay occupy the material realm of
earth while angels occupy the celestial
realm of life it said that jinn reside
in a realm between the material and
celestial called the intermediate realm
a particular story in the Quran tells of
an encounter between the Prophet
Muhammad and a crowd of jinn this tale
describes the jinn as men tall as lances
completely wrapped in their Mantle's
from their feet up who seem to be
composed of blackness interestingly the
55th chapter of the Quran is written in
dual form for both humans and jinn it
describes jinn as practitioners of
religion including Islam who are
believed to have the same religious
responsibilities as humans medieval
Muslim scholars believe the jinn were
susceptible to fiery temperaments
because they were composed of fire so
jinn could either be good or evil the
evil jinn were said to enter into the
bodies of humans causing madness injury
or death an idea that pre-islamic
community's shared as well
human engine interactions weren't always
negative stories of love affairs between
jinn and humans were popular in the
medieval period one of the most famous
interactions between jinn and humans
occur in one of the world's most popular
texts the Thousand and One Nights
scholars argue the famous collection of
stories takes its inspiration from a
number of sources including Indo Persian
and Greek traditions as well as Arabic
Islamic ones one thing for certain is
that although a 9th century fragment and
a 14th century manuscript of the
Thousand and One Nights have been found
there is still no conclusive source
since jinn figure heavily in various
stories we can assume that some aspects
of these creatures exist across many
cultural histories with each translation
and variation of the text older and
newer tales were added and subtracted
regularly but the jinn appear in all
known editions
one significant story in the collection
is the story of the fisherman in it an
old man's slog through a hard day of
work with nothing to show for it after
casting his net many times he draws up a
bottle of brass with heavy lead stopper
stamped with the seal of a dead Sultan
when he opens the bottle a plume of
smoke rises up and condenses into the
form of a massive you've reached an evil
genie so big his head is inside the
clouds at first the genie have you been
trapped in the bottle for 1,800 years
wants to kill the fisherman but the old
fisherman is clever he challenges the
genie to show him how it was possible
for such a magnificent powerful being to
fit in such a small vessel apparently
very vain the genie turns back into
smoke and enters the bottle little by
little until the fisherman can seal it
up once again trapping the gene after
some negotiation the two come to a
compromise
if the fisherman releases him the genie
will not only let the fisherman live but
will grant him one service once freed
the genie leads the man to a hidden lake
in the desert where he is able to
capture the most exquisitely coloured
fish the rare fish make the fisherman a
very prosperous man another important
tale is the story of the merchant and
the genie
this version tells the story of a
merchant who rests under a tree eating
dates when he carelessly tosses a pit
aside an angry genie appears sword drawn
claiming the pit had struck and killed
his son remember genie cannot be seen by
humans in their natural form before he
slays the man he agrees to give the
merchant a year to get his affairs in
order a year passes and the merchant
returns to the same spot under the tree
and awaits his death while sitting there
three sheiks stumble upon him one by one
each deciding to wait with the doomed
man when the genie finally appears the
Sheikh strike a bargain they will each
tell the entity a story if one of the
stories pleases the genie he will
relinquish one-third of his claim on the
merchants life
luckily each story and presses the genie
and the merchant survives in the early
18th century antoine Galland a French
archaeologist and scholar was the first
person to translate the Arabic
collection into a European language he
procured a three or four volume menus
from the eastern Mediterranean region of
Levant dated between the 14th and 15th
century the translation of these volumes
became a 12 volume series published
between 1704 to 1717 under the title the
Thousand and One Nights
Arab stories translated into French
despite containing only 280 nights the
series was a hit for nearly a century
this version became the main text for
subsequent translations and ironically
in 1814 Galan's French text was
translated back to Arabic well the
original Arabic source faded into
obscurity besides becoming the most
commonly translated version for many
years gallons tax gave the world
something else the stories of Aladdin
and Alibaba he added these to the
collection from oral versions reportedly
told to him by a monk from Syria both
stories have no direct Arabic source the
title Arabian Nights entertainments was
first given to the Thousand and One
Nights collection by an anonymous grub
Street English translator of gallons
version and 1706 arguably part of the
reason all the versions of the Thousand
and One Nights became instant sensations
is because Europeans hope to gain some
insight into the lands they had
colonized despite being sensationalized
and exaggerated to say the least the
stories were seen as a window into
foreign cultures in 1840 Edward William
Lane published the first direct Arabic
to English edition based on an Egyptian
version of stories at lanes request this
Arabic version was corrected and
annotated by Sheikh Mohammed Alton Tawi
who helped translate the challenging
Middle Arabic words for more easy
conversion to English lanes version also
included detailed research notes on
Arabic culture as well as illustrations
in some Islamic traditions today the
gener said to still roam the earth
hidden from humans and among some people
is believed that jinn are the cause of
mental illness hallucinations epilepsy
and other conditions are said to be the
work of jinn when one considers that
gener part of muslim religious tradition
it's understandable that people would
think this much in the same way other
religions conceptualize demonic
possession a genie occupying a human's
body is one
explanation for seemingly uncontrollable
behavior the word Genie is an Anglican
eyes version of the French word first
used by Galan in 1706 a term itself
borrowed from the Latin word genius
referencing a supernatural guardian
spirit
the first reference of the genie
granting three wishes also appeared in
gallons text in his rendition of the
story of the fishermen in that story the
genie explains that he initially thought
about granting the person who freed him
from the bottle three demands every day
since then the three demands or wishes
have become a common jinn trope even
appearing the first time a genie appears
in film the iconic genie portrayed by
Robin Williams in Disney's 1992 Aladdin
is a hybrid of all these iterations
Creek and then however this time the
genie rain Taine's some control over the
three wishes he must grant giving
Aladdin stipulations including that he
cannot wish for more wishes what he
wishes to be exact and ixnay on the
wishing for more wishes from spiritual
being - comical cartoon that's quite a
journey jinn have shown up in traditions
and stories since the pre-islamic Arabic
world but it wasn't until a few stories
were translated in the 18th century that
these beings were popularized they're
more than just some blue guy trapped in
a lamp who grants wishes they're
powerful intellectual entities whose
stories are woven into ancient Islamic
culture and yes also capable of changing
the direction of your life in an instant
in an instant oh hell no it snaps
you